il a fait les coupes d'année du club
dorothée clair c'est bernard minet
oui
gilles ragot peu rétro la terre en
option
john ragots
accompli sa mission
[Musique]
d
galaxy
ou suite à l'ugta pernal qui vient
gadrat
[Applaudissements]
kana
les chevaliers janvier
des quatre coins de l'univers
en triomphe eu le mal
sans hésiter qui partent en guerre
vous
il ya longtemps
chevaliers du zodiaque
sens toujours mal attaque
on nous entende
chansons bien aux directions sont des
héros
[Musique]
moi tu es en vie
aké n'gbo le plus mal heureux d
oui il
est
ap
du temps par appel
aventure
qui
[Musique]
et
les boxeurs
dumas
et
[Musique]
oubliée
qu'ils soient et
moi j'ai en mémoire des mots je n'ai
plus mal
les bras
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]